ce que gilles verdez il est quand même
connu sur ce plateau pour être procureur
pourra être grande gueule mais en vérité
moi je le croise souvent dans mon
quartier dans la rue ah oui et le
comportement est tout autre ah oui ils
marchent à grandes enjambées or le
regard vers l'horizon de ses moyens
réalisateur dans cette émission parce
que je le vois il est complètement à
l'ouest et le masque sur le visage j'ai
l'impression qu'ils assument pas en
public ce qu'il dit
c'est vrai c'est à dire j'ai pas dû qu'à
l'écouter victimes
non sont détaillés avec un décalage
entre la personnalité parce qu'à paris
mais est grande gueule bassin et
contrairement au dehors où il est très
discrète et c'est la révélation il est
fini c'est ça et tu as des gemmes le
même mode gay mais non vous l'avez déjà
vu dans une boîte il ya une autre
personne que tu aurais vu dans une boîte
gay alors oui je peux pas le dire
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
non non plus un club
non il s'enlève sinon plus encore - mais
c'est quoi ces entre les deux cela clair
même ravi tous ces familles généralement
c'est clair si on a eu une chez moi
c'est que tu sais quoi c'est l'info
média m'avait toujours répété non
nasa avait reporté voire narraway
olalalala j'ai entendu et péter fait
péter les garder en fin d'émission ni
assez grave nan moi je veux me le dire
je suis pas tonneau mais moi je vais le
dire
moi je veux dire si on ne peut pas dire
prix non plus que j'ai entendu s'il est
tentant oui c'est sûr voilà c'est tout
ok genton soirée entre mme gourmand
qu'on est gay mais il a raison c'est pas
parce qu'on mange des glaces pour les
glaciers on hamm est la raison n'en est
pas encore là mais quand on est quand
même bon pourquoi donnerait alors
c'était fou en fait vous allez
interpréter cette émission mais je veux
pas non je veux pas briser cette
initiative la récession non mais ils
sont fous or ils sont fous non je serais
lui je laquelle regardant notre courte
la crazy mort la terrible envie de
wels accesible follivores l'équipe roc
un combat ris avec des crises avec
l'écran mais elle a pas non tu pourras
que
oui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
oui
il y en a qu'une ça consomme sur place
c'est tibus méconnaît le gibus il ya une
salle noire et bien sûr du
gibus ce que j'ai lu aussi il ya très
longtemps oui oui à bail est aussi tu
t'es fait très longtemps non non juste
des trajets plus ça va il ya une salle
noire quoi way and back ou quoi ouais
chrome non c'est pas maintenant alors
guillaume encore être barré en fait
c'est un bar très particulier à savoir
qu'il ya des douches oui et dans
lesquels il ya des hommes musclés qui
prennent leur douche devant tout le
monde et je suis restée très proche de
la douche mois we were a boy est un
homme qui se douche à chypre a l'air de
partir pour un verre de sirop terme
inter devant des
proches de la paroisse du gros couac
exclamé s'excuser alors ça on apprend
des choses avec le plus jeune on me l'a
proposé ça de quoi nous prendre à moi je
bossais dans le marais gt gt serveurs
dans le marais en toi en face à l'étoile
montante et donc dans la rue
effectivement il ya ça la rue les
archives et bien il y avait
effectivement ce raid ben arfa un petit
peu plus loin et pendant que tu prends
un verre oui il ya un mec qu'elle aille
fait lobao des tirs sur un truc et prend
une douche quand tu prends un vrai rival
et imaginent ils fait ça
je la même scène avec raymond
[Rires]
l'a écouté un petit peu gaulle et ce
n'était pas très pays à l'époque ce
n'était pas alors il paraît qu'ils ont
des si je peux me permettre voulez vous
des zizis en plastique non mais alors
vrai ou non non je pense qu'elle va
emmener le l'enlevait je sais encore je
lui mette la main au niveau et on est
d'accord mais qu'est ce que tu peux tu
es toi surtout là-bas prendre un verre
et tout le temps quand il a acheté
décision plastique pour un cadeau j'ai
enquêté ce sont des [ __ ] de synthèse
encore non mais c'est vrai que ce qu'il
foutait là bas ce sont des endroits où
il n'y a que des gays est le premier des
mecs qui prennent des douches ni bail
alors il fait cela il n'ya pas le
problème et pas un reggae mais à l'aube
et alors je dois d'y aller oui je suis
non binaire